good morning believe nation today's
message is stop thinking over to you
Mitt Romney you hear the expression all
the time you know the grass is greener
on the other side of the fence but don't
forget you could only make the grass
greener on your own side of the fence
you can't change the color of the grass
over there you can only change the color
of the fence on your side and so the
real issue is where is the best
opportunity where can you find
opportunities in your life where's there
an opportunity for instance to start a
new business I've met a lot of
entrepreneurs who started businesses and
most folks think that they're gonna sit
down in their study and think and think
and read magazines and trying to find
some opportunity that that'll allow them
to become rich by starting a business I
haven't found a lot of people do that
most of the people that I have found
that we're successful in starting a
business of their own looked around them
in the job they already had and and
looked for opportunities that weren't
being filled by their their current
enterprise looked for customer needs
that weren't being met look for
something that this wasn't working
particularly well so MIT Romney opened
up that clip talking about the grass is
greener on the other side and I think
it's really important not to compare
yourself to other people don't compare
yourself to where your parents ride
they'll compare yourself to where your
friends are at the real dangers is
comparing yourself to other people who
are your same age but more successful
than you are really the only person you
want to compare yourself to is yourself
and making sure that you're better than
who you were yesterday and you're moving
forward on your goals now to the main
point of stop thinking and start doing
what's important to understand is that
you're never gonna have the perfect plan
no matter how much you plan and plan and
plan and plan and plan it's never going
to be the perfect plan and it's always
going to change you know from the the
day you get into business your plan will
change
and just look at my youtube channel as
an example look at how many times I've
changed my structure how many times have
introduced new series and canceled old
series if I just sat down and thought
about the perfect scenario and just
planned and playing them playing and
never did anything that I never test my
assumptions and I never get anywhere
well instead it's better to think a
little bit but then do go try test your
assumptions see what work and see what
doesn't and I guarantee you you'll end
up with a business model that you never
thought of when you first got into it
and so stop thinking so much and start
actually doing thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso